will smith has apologized to chris rock
for smacking him across the face during
sunday night's oscars after chris made a
joke about jada pinkett smith's bald
head yeah so will did apologize to the
academy and his fellow nominees during
his best actor acceptance speech but has
now issued a direct apology to chris on
his instagram he writes in parts i would
like to publicly apologize to you chris
i was out of line and i was wrong i am
embarrassed and my actions were not
indicative of the man i want to be there
is no place for violence in a world of
love and kindness uh yeah will also
admitted that his behavior was
unacceptable and in excusable writing
jokes at my expense are part of the job
but a joke about jada's medical
condition was too much for me to bear
and i reacted emotionally now according
to tmz chris didn't know jada suffers
from alopecia but the source telling the
outlet chris doesn't have a mean bone in
his body jada now has been very open
about her hair loss battle in the past
and actually spoke confidently about her
bald head less than a week before
sunday's oscars
i don't give two craps what people feel
about this bald head of mine because
guess what
i love it
[Music]
yeah and uh uh jada seemingly broke her
silence after the oscars incident taking
to instagram to share a message to her
fans that reads this this is a season
for healing and i'm here for it
meanwhile will smith's mom carolyn spoke
with 6abc and it sounds like the
altercation really caught her off guard
as she tells the news outlet he is a
very even people person that's the first
time i've ever seen him go off first
time in his lifetime i've never seen him
do that yeah now in response to the
incident the academy said sunday night
that it does not condone violence of any
form by monday afternoon the academy
stated that it was that it condemns
will's actions revealing that a formal
review has been launched
wow
so much to unpack yeah jeez
and i know we're going to get to a lot
of the a lot of the reaction and
i think that something that hollywood
has tried to deny and tried to hide for
a very very very long time was laid out
on the biggest stage for all the world's
eyes to see and we all saw it and that
is
awful things happen and people do awful
things and you hear rumors of things
people have done and said that you don't
want to believe because they don't seem
to be true and the reality is all of
those things happen and in show business
immediately the entire
population collectively pretend it
didn't happen
and then they go on to reward the person
who did the awful thing a standing
ovation that is hollywood if you wonder
how things when you hear these stories
over the years how could this have
happened how could nobody have said
anything how can all these people still
work with this person that happened and
you watch the room react the way they're
trained to react to protect themselves
and that is a room full of the most
privileged and rich people in the world
and you saw how they reacted they
pretended like it didn't happen and they
let him stay and in 20 minutes they gave
him a standing ovation because that's
what they do if you think you know these
people you do not because this is who
they are collectively it is such a good
point and then allowing a basically six
minute acceptance speech without playing
the music to play him off like it was
just wild so here's here's the issue
that i have with this apology so you
know the slap the the yelling from his
seat
the winning best actor the speech and
then it was posing on
the after party red carpets with his
whole family oh yeah in the after party
singing to his own music looking like he
is having the time of his life i mean
this just got weirder and weirder and
weirder to your point i understand it it
almost felt like he was in this
protective bubble but what was going on
all over social media and i'm sure in
your own houses we were like wait
what just happened and how come he was
allowed to stay he didn't get arrested
like once i heard the lapd he had to get
involved i was like okay this makes a
little bit more sense
it is it is an odd thing to see but
again you have to understand and and
for will smith i'm more than positive
that he this is not one thing this is
the culmination of right
i understand
and i and i and i get that and this
isn't about that but what you saw in
that room where you you saw will smith
walk up on stage and assault somebody
and then you saw everybody in that room
who are icons
walk up to will to make sure he was okay
i know
and that right there is all you need to
know about
it's so true it was the denzel you know
washington moment and almost like
they're smiling after and and people
hugging him and you're like is chris
rock okay yeah like is everyone do it
like what is happening and again and i
don't know whether it's you know will
because he's such a nice guy i know
everyone seems to love him and all of
that stuff where you have a hard time
believing that something like that could
happen you know but it was like it was
the perfect person on stage and it was
the perfect moment and will is the sort
of perfect guy to have done that uh to
get the reaction that it did if josh
brolin walked up on stage and slapped
timothy chalamet across the face i think
he would have been arrested he would he
would have been arrested i agree but
there's something about the dynamic of
those two specific individuals and i
don't and i don't know there was a lot
in there was a lot in play but um but
yeah i mean and and i was looking at the
poll aside from the slap and everything
else i was just looking at a poll before
we started this where half the people it
might have been i don't even know what
it was maybe new york post or something
like that where they had said half the
people they pulled agreed with what will
smith did oh and there's and there's a
there's a lot of people that there's a
lot of people that do agree with what
will smith well i have seen people
romanticize what he did in terms of
protecting his his you know wife
and i mean look everyone has a right to
their own opinions and and everyone
views things differently it's just at
the end of the day he assaulted somebody
on stage and knowing that it was live
kind of didn't care and then didn't take
the time to maybe not go to the after
parties and reflect so when this apology
comes out
like are we buying it i'm not really
sure um so it's just still it's still
wild i mean you make such a good point
but i stopped still i still can't
believe that happened yeah yeah and jeez
and you know for chris rock to be able
to just continue on and do his thing
right and it was it was interesting i
was
listening to jimmy kimmel and obviously
he's hosted the oscars he's like i would
have started crime yeah i would have run
off the stage and started crying sure
yeah yeah yeah no absolutely you know
absolutely and it's and it's tough
because when you look at the amount of
people who do back what he
what uh what will smith did it it says
so we're moving into this thing where
you know uh words are violence and all
of this stuff and things like this
become justified to a great number of
people and when you look at the numbers
and a lot of the reaction i mean i love
tiffany haddish but you know what she
said it was a beautiful thing on the red
carpet at the after party i was like oh
my god you are not alone you are not
alone and there's a lot of people who
who feel that way